we take our eight-legged Hall back to
the village where mr. Paul's cousin
shows me her recipe for Cambodia's
favorite snack great stove after killing
the trenchless and boiling them in
salted water for a couple of minutes
they're simply deep-fried in hot oil
Jesus Christ they're crispy Armour
finger-lickin tarantula after a few
minutes they're ready for eating look at
that and the whole village has turned up
to see how the Westerner likes their
local speciality at the moment we will
be waiting for ok how this yeah yeah
good hmm
I'm glad they're happy after the legs
mr. Paul shows me the part of the trench
ler that is most highly prized by the
true connoisseur the belly yeah pull it
off something yeah full of pus yeah yeah
I've eaten some weird things in my time
but I'm really not sure about this
mid huh I yeah it's very bitter I can I
just say I prefer the legs weird texture
when you're biting into it first off
it's like mmm crunchy chicken thigh and
delicious bite through it and all the
sudden burst of sweetness
then it's the body it's like a sort of
bitter bile sour taste it's been a long
day
after I said my goodbyes I hit the road
as surprising as it was I don't think
I'll be putting trench on the menu for
the royal dinner